[Musique]
ton chien et vois leur réaction
salut c'est moi le grand et puissant cher
et je suis sur
tic tac salut
c'est moi
cher
sur tic tac
devine devine qui je suis je suis en débardeur
salut
bien sur tu sais qui je suis  j'allais
me présenter mais pas de joyeux
mois de fierté pour tous les membres de la
communauté que j'aime et cela signifie que vous
êtes
[Music]
oh quels écouteurs utilisez-vous,
voici les écouteurs bose quietcomfort
aussi si vous écoutez cette chanson  avec
ces écouteurs, vous allez pouvoir
entendre des choses que vous n'entendez pas avec
d'autres écouteurs, par exemple, voici à
nouveau cette guitare très forte,
mais saviez-vous qu'il y a un piano secret
caché avec ces guitares,
cela
équivaut à cela,
mais écoutez  avec ceux-ci et vous pourrez
entendre ces couches secrètes que j'ai mises
dans ma musique
mon